stage lune prana
féminin
Harmoniser l'énergie avec la lune et ses cycles
Au début du XXe siècle, le sociologue allemand
Max Weber faisait le constat que le discours
religieux avait de moins en moins d’emprise
dans les sociétés occidentales. Il nomme ce
phénomène le « désenchantement du monde ».
Beaucoup y voient l’aboutissement d’un très
long processus de sécularisation, c’est-à-dire
de transfert du pouvoir des mains de l'Église
vers celles de l’État. Initié à la fin du
Moyen-âge, ce phénomène devrait logiquement
voir disparaître la religion toute entière.
Mais on le sait, la prophétie ne s’est pas
réalisée, les religions n’ont pas disparu en
Occident, ni nulle part ailleurs. La part des
Européens qui étaient des pratiquants réguliers
de leur religion au début des années 2000 est
bien tombée à 30% de la population. Mais la part
des athées, c’est-à-dire des personnes qui pensent
qu’il n’y a pas de dieu du tout, est encore bien
plus faible que ça. Entre ces deux extrémités,
il reste une majorité de personnes qui ont des
croyances et des pratiques plus originales.
De nouvelles spiritualités, souvent hybrides,
sont apparues et répandent leur imaginaire
jusque dans nos smartphones. Dans cette vidéo,
on va donc volontairement laisser de côté les
grands monothéismes avec clergé, textes
sacrés et lieux de cultes bien identifiés,
pour se focaliser sur des mouvements plus
discrets et analyser le discours qu’ils propagent.
Bien sûr, il y a une telle diversité de pratiques
et de croyances qu’on ne pourra pas tout citer,
donc si vous avez d’autres exemples intéressants,
n’hésitez pas à les mentionner en commentaire.
Mais paradoxalement, cette profusion ne traduit
pas pour autant une grande diversité de visions du
monde. L’immense majorité de ces nouveaux courants
sont plutôt des rejetons d’un seul et même schéma
religieux. Avant d’en donner une analyse, il faut
décrire quelques exemples pour s’en rendre compte.
L’une des mouvances les plus influentes et en
même temps l’une des plus intéressantes pour
notre propos est la Société théosophique. Fondée
à New York en 1875, par Helena Blavatsky et Henry
Stell Olcott, elle a pour but de diffuser les
religions indiennes en Occident et de participer
ainsi à une unification des religions mondiales.
Le mot “théosophie” signifie sagesse divine,
ce qui synthétise bien l’objectif du mouvement
: trouver derrière la diversité des croyances,
une sagesse unique. En 1889, dans La Clef de
la théosophie, Helena Blavatsky annonce : «
Notre premier objectif est de constituer le noyau
d’une fraternité universelle de l’humanité sans
distinction de race, de couleur ou de croyance. »
Mais pour faire cela, il faut réinterpréter,
tordre, ou carrément transformer les différents
concepts religieux pour les faire rentrer dans
un cadre unique. Le grand mélange opéré
par la théosophie est bien visible dans
le symbole qu’elle utilise. (Animation
du symbole) Il associe une svastika,
symbole omniprésent dans les religions
indiennes, une étoile de David,
une croix ansée égyptienne ou ankh,
l’ouroboros, un serpent qui se mord
la queue présent dans plusieurs mythologies
et enfin la syllabe sacrée hindouiste Aum.
On a saisi l’idée générale, on pioche un peu
partout pour faire une religion à la carte.
Cette façon de faire porte un nom en
anthropologie, c’est un syncrétisme,
c’est-à-dire un amalgame de plusieurs
traditions, mythes et rituels pour former
une religion. Le syncrétisme opéré par la
théosophie est toujours à la base de nombreux
autres courants religieux actuels, parfois sans
que cela soit vraiment conscient d’ailleurs.
L’anthroposophie de Rudolf Steiner est l’un des
dérivés de la théosophie. Steiner est membre de
la Société théosophique, mais quitte le mouvement
et fonde le sien en 1912. Il remplace le préfixe
“théos” par “anthropos”, l’homme. Cela traduit
sa volonté d’une organisation plus horizontale,
au contact de la société et plus dans la mystique
individuelle. En effet, l’anthroposophie refuse de
se considérer comme une religion, mais se voit
comme une « science de l’esprit ». Pourtant son
fondateur postulait la possibilité de communiquer
avec les morts, la réincarnation des esprits,
imaginait que les maladies sont prédestinées, ou
encore que les forces astrales régissent nos vies.
Mais les instructions de Steiner dans le
domaine de l’agriculture et de l’éducation
ont eu un certain succès. Il y a aujourd’hui dans
le monde de nombreuses écoles Steiner. En France,
leurs méthodes sont régulièrement dénoncées dans
les rapports de la Mission de lutte contre les
dérives sectaires. Côté agriculture, cela a
donné la « biodynamie », que beaucoup de gens
confondent encore avec l’agriculture biologique.
La biodynamie est en fait un ensemble de pratiques
dont certaines peuvent être qualifiées de néo
druidiques : à base de cornes remplies de bouse,
de vessies de cerf et d’un calendrier rituel.
Il y a d’ailleurs un organisme de certification
de la biodynamie, le label Demeter,
affilié à la société d’anthroposophie,
qui certifie le respect de ce rituel, un peu
comme pour la nourriture halal ou casher. Alors
ça paraît assez difficile à croire, mais en allant
sur leur site, on est tout de suite confronté au
discours ésotérique et c’est aussi bien présent
dans le cahier des charges pour obtenir le label.
L’anthroposophie est un mouvement qui
possède par ailleurs des réseaux d’influence,
notamment auprès du parti écologiste allemand
et grâce à l’entreprise Weleda qu’elle détient,
leader européen des cosmétiques bio. En
France, l’ancienne ministre de la culture
Françoise Nyssen ou l’agriculteur Pierre Rabhi,
se sont faits les relais de cette vision du monde
Le New Age au sens propre est l’attente d’une
nouvelle ère. C’est une théorie ésotérique
inspirée d’un astrologue français, Paul Le Cour,
qui annonce en 1937 que l’ère du Poisson va se
terminer et que celle du Verseau s’apprête à
débuter, et transformera profondément l’humanité.
C’est en réalité une croyance millénariste,
c’est-à-dire l’attente d’un âge meilleur,
celui d’une prise de conscience planétaire,
amenant la paix et le bonheur, mais cette
fois-ci, sans l’intervention d’un messie.
Il n’y a bien entendu pas de doctrine unifiée au
New Age, c’est plutôt une nébuleuse de croyances.
Il y a toutefois des fondements largement partagés
comme le monisme spiritualiste, l’idée que
l’univers est un. La conscience humaine peut
entrer en résonance avec lui, donc s’affranchir
de barrières physiques grâce à son esprit. Cela
débouche par exemple sur l’idée que la Terre
est une entité vivante et consciente, ce que
certains nomment la théorie Gaïa. Autre thème
récurrent du New Age, la possibilité d’entrer
en communication avec des êtres invisibles,
d’où l’intérêt pour les pratiques chamaniques,
réinterprétées dans un cadre occidental
contemporain. Ça mérite une explication.
Le chamanisme est, on le rappelle, un
terme qui désigne un ensemble de pratiques
magico-religieuses. Le mot de chaman a
été emprunté aux Toungouses de Sibérie,
là où les premières pratiques sont observées par
les Russes au XVIIe siècle. Mais le chamanisme est
aussi répandu en Amérique, très probablement
diffusé par les populations sibériennes qui
ont peuplé le continent américain à
la Préhistoire. Dans ces pratiques,
le chaman subit une révélation de la part
d’un esprit, par qui il est ensuite initié,
et ressort investi d’un pouvoir surnaturel.
Dans la rhétorique New-Age, le chamanisme joue le
rôle de la tradition authentique par excellence,
elle est pensée comme commune à toute l’humanité.
Il faut avouer que les anthropologues ont leur
part de responsabilité dans cette affaire,
puisqu’ils ont longtemps considéré le chamanisme
comme LA religion universelle de la Préhistoire.
Cet aspect primitif, ancestral et authentique en a
fait un centre d’intérêt majeur pour les nouvelles
spiritualités en quête de pratiques originales.
Le chamanisme se retrouve donc aujourd’hui
dilué dans la globalisation et les séjours
d’initiation en Amazonie à base de diverses
drogues traditionnelles se sont multipliés. On
nous vend par exemple des voyages au Pérou pour
faire du yoga en prenant de l’ayahuasca.
Le yoga donc, rituel typiquement péruvien.
Il y a beaucoup d’autres exemples de nouvelles
spiritualités qui ont émergé depuis le XIXe
siècle : le spiritisme, le bahaïsme,
l’Eglise mooniste de l’unification,
la scientologie ou même le mouvement raëlien, on
pourrait en citer à la pelle. Certaines sont très
axées sur la nature, d’autres au contraire
recourent à des technologies mystérieuses
et sophistiquées pour sonder l’âme de leurs
adeptes. Mais sous leurs aspects très divers,
on peut toutefois leur trouver une unité. Le
travail qu’a mené le sociologue Raphaël Liogier,
synthétisé dans ce livre, Souci de soi, conscience
du monde, permet d’y voir un peu plus clair.
Liogier montre en fait qu’il y a
toujours trois pôles qui sont présents
dans le discours des nouvelles spiritualités
: le bien-être, la créativité et la gnose.
Le bien-être, tout d’abord, est
une notion pratiquement absente des
religions anciennes. Les doctrines comme
le christianisme par exemple, font plutôt
l’apologie du renoncement et glorifient ceux qui
endurent les souffrances voire meurent pour le
bien de la cause. Au contraire, les nouvelles
spiritualités, elles, proposent à leurs adeptes
d’accéder à un bonheur immédiat grâce à leurs
enseignements, pas une fois arrivés au paradis.
Deuxième aspect, la créativité, qui est conçue
comme l’expression de soi. Les adeptes sont
invités à expérimenter, à ressentir, à se
révéler par leurs pratiques spirituelles.
C’est l’affirmation de l’individu, à
l’opposé encore une fois des anciennes
religions, qui demandaient plutôt de se
conformer à un rituel très standardisé.
Dernier aspect, la gnose, le contraire
d’agnostique. Un agnostique c’est quelqu’un
qui n’a pas d’explication préconçue, qui dit
“je ne sais pas ce qu’il y a après la mort”
par exemple. La gnose c’est donc être persuadé
d’avoir une connaissance intuitive du monde, une
compréhension des forces divines. C’est ce qui ne
peut pas être expliqué, et qui doit être cru grâce
à une révélation ou un rituel. C’est ce qui est
présent aussi dans les religions traditionnelles.
Ces trois pôles se mêlent dans les différents
mouvements qu’on a décrits et chacun accorde plus
ou moins de poids à l’un ou à l’autre. Plus ils
mettent l’accent sur la gnose, la mystique, plus
ils sont connotés religieusement et susceptibles
d’être assimilés à des sectes par le pouvoir.
Mais si on creuse un peu, on s’aperçoit que
le triptyque bien-être/créativité/gnose est
en réalité présent dans beaucoup
d’autres domaines de nos sociétés.
Le discours commercial est aujourd’hui truffé de
références spirituelles. Les produits alimentaires
ou du secteur du tourisme mettent eux l’accent
sur le bien-être. Le monde de l’entreprise
insiste davantage sur la créativité. Mais l’aspect
mystique n’est jamais loin, il suffit de rentrer
dans un magasin bio pour s’en rendre compte
: lampes à cristaux et autres produits aux
vertus énergisantes participent de ce discours
qui n’a rien de scientifique. Dans le monde du
travail aussi la dérive n’est jamais loin comme
l’a montré Cash Investigation avec son enquête
sur les stages de formation professionnelle.
Cette rhétorique de la créativité et de
l’individualisation est tellement récurrente
qu’elle a même été adoptée un temps par les
campagnes de recrutement dans l’armée française.
Entre 2010 et 2012 le slogan du recrutement
était « Devenez vous-même » ! Pourtant l’armée est
loin d’être une institution où l’on peut exprimer
sa différence : uniforme pour tout le monde et
obéissance aveugle, on a fait plus créatif. Dans
ce cas-là, il n’y a rien de particulièrement
religieux, on est d’accord, mais ça illustre
la capacité du discours à s’immiscer partout.
Des magazines tels que Psychologies s’en font
le relais également depuis longtemps. Son
propos est très axé bien-être et créativité,
mais la gnose n’est pas absente, lorsqu’il est
question de trouver la paix intérieure grâce à la
méditation par exemple. On retrouve tout cela de
manière générale dans les livres de «développement
personnel », qui fleurissent partout depuis le
succès mondial des Quatre accords toltèques de
Miguel Ruiz en 1997. (pas Migouel, Mig-el
!) Cette rhétorique vise en particulier
beaucoup les femmes auxquelles la plupart de ces
publications sont destinées. Un site comme Goop,
tenu par l’ancienne actrice Gwyneth Paltrow est
truffé de remèdes pseudo-scientifiques destinés
à aider les femmes en délivrant un discours
spirituel sur la divine énergie féminine
En fait, le discours des nouvelles spiritualités
est déjà un discours dominant. Il a été largement
adopté par le marketing, les institutions,
les œuvres culturelles, etc. L’exemple le
plus flagrant reste sans doute le film Avatar
de James Cameron, sorti en 2009 dans lequel on
retrouve tous les ingrédients qu’on a décrits.
Individualité et créativité s’invitent même dans
les grands monothéismes et les bouleversent
déjà. Un exemple ? Le port du voile intégral,
qui fait tant parler et qu’on interprète
toujours comme le signe d’un obscurantisme
moyenâgeux. Les enquêtes sociologiques comme
celle d’Agnès de Féo dans son film Sous la burqa,
qui donne la parole aux femmes qui la porte,
montrent qu’il s’agit plutôt d’une volonté de
se démarquer, de personnaliser leur pratique.
Sous des aspects très différents, on voit donc
se dessiner un discours assez homogène. Et il
tend à dépasser le simple cadre de la quête
spirituelle pour devenir une véritable idéologie.
Raphaël Liogier, sur qui on s’appuie ici,
propose la notion d’individuo-globalisme pour
la nommer. Alors, il confesse lui-même que la
tournure est un peu lourde, mais cela a le
mérite d’être parlant : individuel + global.
L’individuel, attaché au bien-être,
type développement personnel,
à la personnalisation ; et le global, l’attention
portée au cosmos, à l’harmonie, éventuellement au
développement durable. Voilà en somme, la toile de
fond qui engloberait ces nouvelles spiritualités.
Difficile de ne pas voir dans cette attention
portée au global une conséquence de la
mondialisation. L’économie mondialisée avec
le marketing notamment participe en fait de
la diffusion de l’idéologie individuo-globaliste.
Il est assez frappant de constater d’ailleurs une
forme de fusion des discours économique
et religieux. La sacralisation des flux,
de l’énergie, et au contraire la
diabolisation de l’immobilité et du
blocage, sont aussi des préoccupations
de l’économie capitaliste financiarisée.
Ces nouvelles spiritualités ne sont donc pas
l’expression d’une sagesse antique ou exotique
comme elles le prétendent, mais bien la plus
pure expression de notre réalité contemporaine.
Et s’il y a bien un aspect essentiel de la
société qui est passé directement dans les
nouvelles spiritualités, c’est l’individualisme.
Ces nouveaux mouvements consistent en fait bien
plus en une « privatisation » de la religion
plutôt qu’en un retour au religieux. Il n’est
plus question de lien social et d’institution
organisant la collectivité comme au Moyen-âge,
mais uniquement de satisfaction personnelle.
C’est donc bien une idéologie au cœur
de la mondialisation, mais en même temps, et
étrangement, une contestation de la modernité.
Cette idéologie peut aussi être comprise comme
une forme de contestation. Le mode de vie et
de pensée contemporain, rationalisé
par la science et l’industrie apparaît
pour l’immense majorité de ces nouvelles
spiritualités comme une dangereuse perdition.
Dès le XIXe siècle, le romantisme s’était
construit comme un refus du mécanisme industriel
et un contrepoids à la modernité. Dans les
nouvelles spiritualités comme dans le romantisme,
les discours marginaux et anti-académiques sont
valorisés. La spontanéité et la subjectivité sont
préférées aux démonstrations expérimentales.
Parfois le propos fait quand même appel à la
logique, ou à des théories compliquées telles que
la physique quantique, mais c’est toujours pour
en souligner l’aspect mystique et non rationnel.
C’est en somme l’opposé de l’idéal humaniste des
Lumières, et c’est en cela qu’on peut dire que
c’est un mouvement contestataire. La rationalité
est vécue, de manière générale, comme un obstacle
à la connaissance de la vérité, un obstacle à la
liberté, que seules des pratiques spirituelles
et mystiques peuvent permettre d’atteindre.
Un discours contestataire mais qui devient
dominant… ça s’appelle une révolution non ?
Les effets des changements qu’on a décrits
sont difficiles à connaître. Bien que les
transformations soient assez lentes, elles
sont, on l’a vu, assez radicales. Quand on
voit à quel point les savants prophétisant la
fin des religions se sont trompés, il paraît
très imprudent de faire un pronostic catégorique
pour l’avenir. Révolution religieuse de grande
ampleur ? Unification progressive de tous les
cultes sous une seule idéologie ? Peut-être,
mais il faut bien voir que ces nouvelles
spiritualités ne se développent pas dans
le monde entier. Pour se préoccuper de son
bien-être et de de l’harmonie avec le cosmos,
il faut être matériellement à l’abri,
autrement dit, suffisamment riche
pour ne pas se préoccuper de sa survie.
Ce qui paraît inéluctable, c’est que les
religions traditionnelles vont devoir continuer
de s’adapter à ces transformations, en tenant
compte des nouvelles et nombreuses attentes
spirituelles qui se diffusent avec le mode de vie
contemporain. Le monde des individus globalisés
est décidément bien loin d’être désenchanté.